okay so let's get into the game
my first game today which was round
three I was black against national
master tin making tea I have the name
here and we actually played like ten
years ago
and back then I played the Budapest
I played the blue the best against him
and and I drew him ten years ago I was
like a really good result for me because
I was a low-rated back then but today I
was playing for a win and I kind of knew
what to expect
he played the nimzo-indian yeah this is
expected I found a few of his games
beforehand he played III and there's a
lot of different options for black here
back in Castle this this so white has a
lot to be prepared for
I played b6 it's a line that I played
recently and the norm tournament in st.
Louis and the idea is to play an early
Bishop a6 I guess it's important to
understand White's idea when white plays
III sometimes idea is just to develop
like normally but I knew that he plays a
slide with night GE 2 and then a 3 to
try and just get the bishop pair and
then avoid double plums so the idea of
b6 is that after 92 Bishop a6 and I
simply attack the pawn and it's a little
bit annoying for white to deal with but
it's okay it's a variation he played
three takes takes and then I play d5 so
this is the best way to justify the
bishop it's no good for white to take
because then white would lose castling
rights this is very nice for black how'd
you remember what you played 10 years
ago so growing up I would save all of my
games to chess base and I would review
them on occasion so like the game I
played 10 years ago it's saved somewhere
in Chesapeake
and back then I had a PGN of like all my
games and once in a while I would just
go through and look at stats so that
game was stuck in my mind it was one of
the first times I actually played the
Budapest in a tournaments
so anyway going back to what happened in
our game he did not take he played b3
actually Queen f3 is an interesting line
we have 3 was what I was kind of
expecting idea to just pin the pawn and
then the main line is castling in g4 and
it's a really cool variation but we
didn't go into that actually after the
game he told me that he forgot this like
he would have play that if he would
remember it but he forgot like the the
line so b3 which is actually most
popular I'm not doing challenges I'm
reviewing games there's a very slim
chance they'll take challenges later but
I have to reflect on my my tournament
play hopefully learn a thing or two yeah
the main challenges I'm accepting are
they're over the board challenges where
I don't have a choice when I'm playing
it's just pairings so anyway b3 then I
started thinking because I wasn't sure
exactly what the line was and I came up
with castling Bishop d3 and then takes
takes actually counseling I played
quickly but I started thinking in this
position and kind of realized that I I
don't have the bishop here and usually
in the nihms oh you give up the bishop
pair to try and gets like counter play
against White's pawn structure and in
this case it's possible after it takes
takes and then interesting move knight
c6 and usually it looks awkward from the
knight to develop in front of the C pawn
but in this position there's ideas of 95
and it spawns a little bit tender so
white castles
then I play d5 and I was feeling pretty
good
I could play 95 right away but then
Queenie too so there is actually a trick
which I was kind of hoping my opponent
would fall into is that after E 5 if
white were to play d5 here which looks
attractive Knight a5 Queenie to black to
move
I think it's black to move and win
material I might be wrong but I think
I'm right
so black to move in win material whoa
it's a raid it's a huge raid
Goldust Tori what's up raiding with a
party of 249 hello what do I call your
people
hello to the GT gang I don't have any
special cheating sound effects but I
have I better have emotes GT gang yeah
GT gang where is it it's this one also
the I'm endangering mode is great shout
outs gold story and shout out chess weed
wellhow fellow streamers shout out chess
weed okay if you're just joining I am
reviewing my round 3 game from the only
open and this is a good point because I
just asked the chat a question right
before the raid this is black to move
and play what I think is the best move
we already have a few suggestions from
cool guy and from liquid sword and hello
took garbonzo genes I guess play on
words to garbanzo beans yeah well done
cool guy efore I think this is just
winning a pond or maybe the exchange
idea is okay Bishop takes this is just
ponderous because takes takes and skewer
c4 square is explosive and then if
Knight takes
then pretty much the same thing but at
the end of this line
Oh in the d5 pawn because Bishop d3 I
can take on d5 probably either away so I
was kind of hoping for that hey sir
raman two out of two today good job
does that make that makes you three out
of four right if I remember correctly
what is the best free chess presentation
software I'll be chess this is what I'm
using right now we chess study you can
save everything organize stuff into
chapters have engine analysis and
stockfish or of yeah stock fish engine
elseis as well as opening explorer in
table base all built in so after yeah
after E 5 my opponent played Knight d5
which is which was kind of a slight
surprise because it looks like this
shouldn't work for whites like I can
just try and win a pawn somehow and I
really wanted to take on d4 so I started
calculating takes takes a knight takes
as possible but let's say pawn takes
takes ticks of hitting the Knights and
then I wanted to play Queen takes d4
counterpunching the rook and it almost
works but White has a really nifty move
in that position rook a to and then
blocks in trouble because the night is
hits if my knight moves then there's
Bishop takes h7 with the discovered
attack and after okay - I would want to
play rook a d8 but then there's rook d2
and then still the double threat of
taking c6 as well as Bishop takes h7 so
it's kind of sad but it wasn't so sad
because I didn't walk into it but I
didn't get to win a pawn so just to show
people who maybe weren't following the
arrows
after it takes takes and like when it
comes to calculating this type of stuff
it's kind of a long variation but it's
pretty forcing like moves are just
captures and clear attack and yeah
brocade - just saves the day if Rick v1
then black would be doing very well here
but Roque - just with a the just keeping
initiative so Roque - it's like a
counter counter punch this is a counter
counter counter punch and this is a
counter counter counter counter punch
music man brings up a good point why not
Knight takes d4 this is another
possibility which I was looking into the
problem with this is that the positions
wide open and white has two bishops and
this one pawn on d5 fixes all these
pawns and White House initiative play
Bishop b2 have initiative threatening to
take and then take on each seven and my
knight can't retreat to c6 and if it
moves here I can keep initiative like
play this I I relied more on intuition
but I just thought this was gonna be
problematic and I thought it would be
difficult to win like in order for me to
win this I would need so like hold on to
my pawn and I thought there's so many
variations where white went in wins back
up on and it was just better cuz right
here is Bishop takes f6 White's gonna
follow up with like d1 or exceed one c7
would be weak so I didn't go into any of
that I decided that I should not
liquidate too soon especially if it's
not so clear why Bishop takes b5 it's
just a forcing line I did not play that
in the game well I played in the game
was rook e8 staying calm trying to
improve the position some idea of maybe
four at some point but really just
finding the best Square for the rook
so Bishop b2 and then I play the move
where like when I
play that I was happy with it but then
after a white plate in the next move I
wasn't happy with it
I played Queen d7 I thought white was
kind of stuck I thought the Queen was
tied down to basically defending the
pawn through x-ray vision and I thought
it would be difficult for white to find
a move here but then the problem was
white just played Queen c2 and when I
initially played Queen d7 I well it's a
sub thanks for the sub Tom carbo subbing
in Tier one appreciate that after Queen
c2 initiai thought I could just win the
pawn on d4 after something like takes I
should know the again that night takes I
would be very happy to have ninety five
but White has a like strong response
here I just Bishop f5 and my queen has
very few squares if it stays defending
the pawn then there's rook let's say
rook a d1 and whites doing very well
here like Center is opening up well I
can take back with pawn next play d5
soon and I would not be happy so my
queen was a bit misplaced on g7 because
rook t1 is coming and even Bishop f5 is
coming in some cases so I played Bishop
e7 realizing my bishop is better on this
diagonal more centralized and I want to
play a six wanted to play a six chased
am i hearing Windows Phone Todd carbo
Syngman watching your vids for a while
things for good content well thanks for
stopping by the stream
I know sometimes there's a difference
between watching on YouTube and watching
on on Twitch ok ass Bishop f5
yeah Bishop f5 it's like almost a queen
shot like my queen just has like just a
couple squares okay so why play Bishop
f5 here but then I was happy just to
slide the Queen over then d5 so white is
throwing punches Knight a5
and then a for I think a for was a
mistake looks logical at first but we'll
get to why it's a mistake if you're just
joining this is my game from round three
at the Illinois Open played earlier
today the game started at 10:00 a.m.
Central Time Chicago time it's now
almost 10:00 p.m. so this game started
almost exactly 12 hours ago I was
playing Tim Nick and T who's a 2204 a
very experienced player but yeah as
people will see actually I won't give
away the results but people will see
what happens so a for preparing this and
it looks scary because my queen is gonna
get chased around but I very simply play
a six here and then whites in a pickle
because if if Knight moves back to c3 I
win the c4 pawn and if fish of a three I
just play Queen d8 and then the knight
only square for the knight is c3 and
then I win the c-4 plot so it turned out
the only move for white after a six is
to play Knight a3 which is a really sad
square for the Knights and got the nice
just out of the game for a while so not
sure what white should have done it was
a little bit tricky because I am
threatening to play Basics in this
position so white should probably
somehow defend this pawn maybe the
bishop should just retreats like the
bishop doesn't belong on an a5 I don't
think and then the knight should retreat
and white should maybe focus in the
center I thought white should maybe at
some point play e4 and then go for f4
and try and use the dark square Bishop
this is only Dartford bishop on the
board I thought it could be unpleasant
if I'd eventually guess f4 in
Knight a3 I've reinforcing the beam once
quitter very key square and then if
night b1 is played then then we're
closer to setting up for the next game
might be one I don't think was played
unfortunately until after we reset the
pieces okay so I play c6
I wanted to open the position at least
open this diagonal because the bishops
staring at this pawn is kind of
depressing
so c6 takes maybe why could have played
e4 I was calculating efore and then g6
and then some knight each five move it
would be interesting but takes takes
Bishop c3 Bishop c8 wanted to trade like
squared bishops I thought that like if
we trade then White's pawn weaknesses
become a bit more glaring and that was
my actually my one advantage is his pawn
structure so why the void of the trade
and then then I play the move which
guarantees me to win a night for Bishop
or win a bishop for Knights might be for
have enough of white having the bishop
hair but it's been interesting every
game I played so far even my round four
game yeah all all four games I played
this tournament I've been the one to
trade a bishop for a knight early on so
I've played like against a bishop hair
all my games okay in some games it was
more just night versus Bishop but I've
had to try and prove the Knights
dominance over bishops okay so night
before um essentially inducing Bishop
takes before and then I was very happy
because yeah these are clear playing
weaknesses and they're also on light
squares and ducha lights for bishops
it's just it's already looking very good
for black
rook p1 in Queen d6 at first I thought
Queen c5 looks more natural but then I
convinced myself Queen d6 actually has a
lot more ideas one idea is that it makes
the Queen tied down to the bishop so
white doesn't have like quick counter
play with trying to win the b6 pawn
because white would have to do something
about this guy and then also Queen c5
would take away the c5 square for my
Knights I thought 97 to c5 is a very
possible maneuver and then the last
possibility is if I do get night guiding
night c5 then my queen can swing over
Sunday to the Kings side and all of that
pretty much happens oh I played h3 I
think White was scared of oh this was
another idea of Queen d6 was efore and
Knights g4 amazing ideas on h2 and then
sometimes if if g3 of the Queen comes to
h6 so lots of arrows
this is thumbnail work worthy this might
be the thumbnail if I put this on
youtube
someday okay so h3 a little bit slope
play Bishop e6
Queen b3 not threatening the pawn
because okay the Queen's tied down to
the bishop but I defend the pawn anyway
and get ready to fork the Queen and the
bishop my opponent saw the threats
followed the Ben Feingold rule always
played Bishop f1 and I play rugby eights
over defending the pawn just so my
knight can come to the promised land
Knight see - yeah so this night was
super depressed it's still kind of sad
on on c2 but he has some idea some day
of playing this in this but it never
happened Knight c5 attacking the Queen
and then dish about five so I think
starting around Queen d6 if we just go
back here the play just flowed really
nicely even going back to night before
like from this position
all my moves just felt very very natural
like just developing and proving finding
betters first my pieces then after a
Bishop f5 lights under a lot of pressure
and there's there's some nice tactical
ideas coming up
first of all Bishop f5 is threatening a
double attack which all asset chats
let's imagine it's black to move here
what can black play to double attack
something ok good job guys
Queen g6 yeah Queen g6 it's a nice
double tech creating the battery so
threatening the knight and threatening
h3 because of the pinned yeah multiple
people found it good job Yvonne elos mr.
waffle truck so gobbler yeah so it was a
sneaky threat because at first it just
looks like I'm pinning but I do have a
threat and I was hoping my opponent
would play rook d1 here after rook t1 I
have a really cool move I don't know if
it works I haven't checked this with the
engine but I think it works well so I
still have Queen g6 yeah I could still
play Queen g6 and just win the win the
pawn on each three I'll just go ahead
and show it I was probably going to play
Knight takes a four even fancier count
you're attacking the Queen and there's
like so many nice lines here for example
takes takes the Knights attack
I'll have Knight e4 with tempo I'm just
up up on a5 will come eventually if the
Queen moves to b4 I would have I just
have Queen c6 like this might still
attacked if Queen takes Knight I win a
exchange in the end I'd just be
completely winning here there any other
line pretty sure all the lines works
like even Queen b3 I just play Queen c6
or no wait Queen b3 Oh Queen b3 I play
Knight c5 just moving back
and just attack you McQueen so it was
nice nice possibility but I think my
opponent saw the threat of queen g6 and
played rook c1 just to defend just
probably one of the best moves and then
I kept improving a5 fixing this pawn
online square and preventing night
before so it's positional in multiple
ways and whites very stuck here like I
thought maybe at some point what would
just be in zones long because things are
tied down I get it started to become
very difficult for a white to to find a
move here why played rook to a - I
played kind of a nifty retreating
attacking move Bishop d7 hitting the
pawn in a for this pawn and it's not
easy to defend white had to play rook c2
a1 and I play Queen b6 so I have
initiative I'm just improving the
process idea Bishop d7 was to maybe put
the bishop along the long diagonal now
Queen d6 I'm threatening Bishop takes h3
so King H - I keep making threats Queen
i5 um Queen i5 I'm just attacking f2 I
was hoping for kim ji-won like there's
so many possible tactics but my opponent
wasn't falling into anything after kim
jiwon I have actually all I'll ask the
chatting and black to move find the best
move okay everyone's saying 94-94 it's a
fork
kind of but light defends with Queen e1
so a good job again - even yellows and
mr. waffle truck and iron robots Queen
takes F to move orders very important
like if you if you see 94 you should
also see Queen takes f2 and then decide
which order is most effective
wait did sub gobbler say easy and not
find it ah
slub gobbler said 94 easy but probably
missed Queen digs left - or you were
hacked also jarek seed hey thanks for
the sub the voice thing is a little bit
messed up because i'm not on my normal
computer it's like some echo but I
appreciate the sub in the comments
okay so sub gobbler was hacked but yeah
okay queen's eggs f2 is simple tactics
and then i would be attacking the rook
in the end wait a minute
what is this okay Knight takes Queen of
course human this Bishop c6 the Knights
almost trapped here like maybe I would
have to bail out with this but okay
Bishop c6 and light returns to e4 so
opponent plate 91 I should also note my
opponent was like under two minutes here
I had about twenty minutes so as a great
position to just kind of keep the
pressure and keep making threats but it
was impressive like my opponent just
wasn't blundering even in time pressure
until it maybe a bit later so I played
Bishop c6 Knight e3 well he wants to
trade play 94 again attacking the Queen
in the pawn Queen B - defending
everything and then I had to figure out
what to do and I decided why not improve
more things Knight g5 Oh some reason I
thought I played rookie six but Knight
g5 unleashing the bishop some ideas of
efore also some ideas of knight takes h3
also ideas are just later lifting the
rook so now you want back sad move then
rookie six so if we look at White's
pieces compared to blacks pieces its
paradise
it's just no it's very comfortable but
it still takes work I think these types
of positions it's it's easy to get
relaxed and get lazy but it did still
take work on my end to actually break
through and then see if I was played
yeah when I played Ricki 6i I saw c5
coming and decided I'd be well off to
put the bishop on d5 and then play this
so what I did was I remove the rook from
helping defend f2 now the Knights is
forking some plums and if pawn takes
pawn I hit the Queen and then almond f2
but yeah he found a good move here
Knight d3 Bishop e3 is illegal
maybe you mean bishop or Bishop e3 is
illegal but you probably mean Bishop d3
if Bishop d3 I think I can just take
getting out of the pin and the Queen's
on defendant on b2 my knight defends my
queen do you think it's good idea for
unrated player on your a they could mean
anything but yeah I mean I think it's
completely fine for the only open to be
like your first raided tournament but it
depends on the player like if they have
enough experience like online and no
over the board rules usually a US Open
every year there's a few unrated players
it's like first turn is like the biggest
term in the US roof welcome back just in
time for the end of my my round 3 game
so my opponent played 93 and then I took
a thing cuz I wasn't sure what to do it
was like a weird position like things
were just kind of tied down I can't take
the pawn because of the pin so I played
what looks like a passive move but I was
actually happy with the move Knight f6
hoof is sobbing gifted by not a GM John
Davis thanks John Davis and thanks booth
for being a loyal fan
only open is in Illinois big surprise
it's in Downers Grove it's a suburb of
Chicago
yeah 12 72 subs that's a huge number
that's like a beginner rated chess
player okay Knight f6 um yeah my knight
was just in the way of things Knight f6
does it makes like three different
things happy it makes everything here
happy unleashes the Queen the bishop
ideas of e4 again also ideas of Knight
d7 to defend the rook break the pin and
then eventually take the pawn also ideas
of Knight g4 like Knight g4 wreck h6
could be cool and then there there is
another idea to which I got to play in
the game after rook c1 I was so happy to
play this move damn g5 think every game
has it been every game maybe not my
round 4 game not my round 4 game but my
first three games g5 occurred in all of
them and in every case chief I was like
a fun kind of aggressive of a few of the
games or one game I opponent played it
but yeah g5 hereit's
it's again multi-purpose I'm creating
moved for the King so I don't want to
get back rank mated and I also want to
play g4 like most of whites pieces are
just on the Queen side not defending the
King and most of my pieces are
contributing to some attack so g5 it's
just a some nice added pressure to to
break this this pawn shelter are you in
contention to win yes it all comes down
to tomorrow I'm tied for second with a
bunch of other players and the guy in
first place is playing the top seed the
guy in first place is an FM he's playing
a GM tomorrow
so I was happy G fine pawn takes pawn
rook takes pawn oh yeah I didn't take
with my ear oke because that hangs the
e5 on so I take with this rook rook c8
King g7 I have some nice initiative
this is attacked also it's important to
note my queen is aligned with this rook
which is relevant and just a few moves
Queen to c1 and then I think at this
point it's just a force win for black
I'll just show it happens before yeah
the night is just driven away from
defending f2 and after Knight c5
attacking my rook I simply move over and
it's a double attack Queen's hitting the
rook my Queens hitting the pawn and once
f2 falls
it's just crushing so my opponent
actually resides here he had less than a
minute
it is pretty hopeless during the game I
really wanted to make Knight g4 work
like Knight g4 takes and then like this
threatening mates I think the problem is
Queen here it gets weird because my King
lacks shelter but then I realized
afterwards that I have work h6 here and
after Kim Ji Won I can take the rook
this wins exchange but I think well I
did in the game is even more troublesome
for for black or for whites just ripped
e6 and I'll have an IG for later it will
be more more powerful so that was my
game I was round 3 I think it was a
solid game I think it's one of these
games where the losing player didn't
make like a huge blunder it just kind of
got worse and worse he fell victim to
time pressure but yeah the middle game
was kind of tense I felt a little bit
worse
around here like after after Queen d7
Queen c2 I just felt worse and then I
think there's some transformation
probably with this a4 move and then
after the c6 move takes takes I think
this is kind of the turning points where
White was left with this ugly pawn
structure and it was very positional and
yeah play flowed very nicely and during
like these the sequence of moves where I
just improved like I was able to play
every move in pretty much less than two
minutes which is pretty quick for this
time control usually I average maybe two
to three minutes and move but it was
nice to just play quick moves and
realize my opponent had very little
active play so there we have it
combination and positional chests
initiative g5